i know you were behind bringing
a lot of people don't remember odb
before he passed dirk mcgirt was on
rockefeller
talk about like mariah picked him up
from jail i just say talk about that
because i feel like that that's like a
part of like the rockefeller uh legacy
we don't hear a lot of because it kind
of was at the tail end of things like
right like when things started to kind
of get interesting but like you know how
i'd be so cloudy bro
i forgot about a lot of that [ __ ]
so much good [ __ ] is happening in the
future
you know like i said when you're having
fun you don't like hold on to certain
things in the past and [ __ ] unless
you're like trying to learn from them
and and i was talking about that
situation the other day with old dirty i
just remember when he died his family
just
you know i went to his mom's house
all his kids was there just they just
was dancing and they were still happy
through that pain
i learned so much from that
you know i think about the good part
what you can learn from dark i gotta
find the light
but it hurt me because he died on my
watch
i tried everything i could do he was the
first one i lost on my watch